do freestyle rap that is rap that's
improvised in the moment based on your
suggestions on what you lovely people
would like to hear a rap about I asked I
asked the organization I said why did
you book me they said well we googled
you and there was a review of you that
said your jokes were sometimes more
clever than they are funny
I was like you realize that's a bad
review right not for us this is
brilliant this is what we want more aha
than haha because we are here to listen
and partake in a debate I will ask for a
couple of suggestions to be kind of mold
in that way so we've got some friends
and couples in the audience I would like
to get a suggestion first from a couple
of a recent debate or argument or
disagreement that you had so if we've
got any couples in the front row who are
willing to share a recent thing here you
people here who you you look both so
handsome but it's also possible you
could be siblings that's how you're both
10 out of 10 so you always got to check
are you a couple
sure
so when when your lady is that
attractive you need to be more confident
you need to be like yes yes
um yes thank you very much yes sir gosh
it feels back over 250 years ago when we
were in charge
um what say a recent a recent
disagreement or debate that you had with
uh with your partner she wakes up at 4
30 in the morning
and then just does that
is that a bad thing that sounds like
someone who's a CEO that sounds like
you're killing it I love it okay a
harmonious relationship except for
someone waking up at 4 30 in the morning
I love it um have we got some friends
down here friends are more willing to to
you you guys Pals yeah cool you're
nodding more enthusiastically than you
sir you're like I don't know we'll see
defensive he's picking up the tab what's
a recent disagreement or thing that
you've chatted about I think we've
chatted about like the US involvement in
Ukraine and what's the right level
it's a great topic to rap about there in
it
so okay a couple where one wakes up at 4
30 and the U.S involvement in Ukraine
those those are the two kind of touchy
issues that were going on One Touch
within the other uh I believe and let's
get a couple more suggestions and these
don't have to be related that they don't
have to be related to the debate just be
as creative and fun as you possibly can
so if you've over the phone shout it out
nice and loud so that uh we can all hear
it
whoopee cushion thank you very much
bringing some levity to the situation
middle of the room what are you guys
going to come up with
dragons dragons yes what's your favorite
thing about dragons my friend
breathing fire of course yeah good and
then let's move over here finally the
final suggestion from you guys what are
you gonna have a rap about
populism
yeah you guys should team up with them
as well be all that's what we want at
the rap show okay so this is going to be
a freestyle as I said a rat made up on
the spot based on your suggestions on a
partner who wakes up at 4 30 whoopee
cushions dragons and how they breathe
fire populism and the US and its
involvement in the Ukraine uh great I
know which section the rapper is going
to be very short and brief so if we can
drop that beat my friend this uh as I
said a freestyle are we going to press
play on that yeah there we go look at
that that's what happened the crowd
completely silent just going this is
going to be the worst thing we've ever
seen it's not it's gonna be incredible
and it's gonna start with with you here
we go
first thing practical joke power start
sitting down on the chair on the head
that far sound I'm like oh no a joke is
near on the whoopee cushion it can say
it's a bronze cheer never understood
what it means as a Young Gun as a
preteen I was Keen playing all the
pranks it's not my fault I used to
switch that Sugar Shaker for salt but
the whoopee filled me with Glee it
sounded like Pooh didn't sound like pee
cause there's not a little noise if you
ask a whoopee cushion for p would just
be a splash or a puddle the starts
expanding gotta get your air in there
expand things then it goes that's the
sound of when it deflates when the thing
goes down oh yes I can break out at the
prison of the mind let me move on to
populism all the time people gather
they're in the field and popular but you
start to feel it doesn't mean that it's
like some things may be leaders there on
the right wing they're like yeah we got
a wild one on maybe shout out someone
like Tucker Carlson trying to appeal to
a very large gang oh yes I might not
understand like my boy over here he'd be
like sir please my lady wakes up early
yeah I'm gonna do a dirty alarm clock
going off at 4 30. please make no
mistaken it's fine if she's cooking me
eggs and bacon but no she's having some
fun she starts exercising maybe going
out on a run does the jogging keeping
ever so fit I'm in bed I feel like a
little lazy person but when she comes
back I prank on her with the whoopee
attack yeah I put it on the sofa cushion
she sits down
then she's blushing it's ever so sad
feels me pain I got shame anyway move on
to Ukraine ah yeah the fun stops war
going on yeah some blocks start blown up
in Keys all the Russians they'd be like
oh we should leave but then Putin he'd
be getting angry asks no I demand that
you're there in the draft off to the
front it's not a thing for comedy in the
U.S maybe they can do it properly put a
lot of millions billions too they're
like careful with this you could have
blew up some things and it's out of
order if they attack over the Russian
border all hell might break loose look I
really brought the mood down for all of
yous but don't worry one thing we admire
dragons in the sky when they're
breathing fire obvious it never fails
you got the fun females there with the
scales going around yes you can see them
on HBO on TV that's how we end not how
we start this spitfall at the dragons
dracary
foreign
[Applause]